hi everyone this is Jeremy's chiefly
with Khan Academy I want to thank you
for joining us this afternoon or this
evening depending on where you're
calling it from and you're in for a very
special treat so as you probably know
we've been doing webinars every day
twice a day three times a day here at
Khan Academy but I have to confess I
have never seen a session like the one
that Tim led a couple weeks ago where he
basically blew minds all across the
country by talking about the results he
got with mastery learning in his
classroom so much so that Tim has gone
on to chat with Sal Khan directly and
will actually be on Sal Khan's live
stream next week if you've been tuning
into that but if you want a sneak
preview into what he and Sal are going
to talk about you've come to the right
place that this is way more than a sneak
preview thanks to the generosity of Tim
we're gonna get a deep dive into
everything he does in his classroom the
actual use of Khan Academy his gradebook
and all that good detail so you can
apply the same in your own classroom
either tomorrow or even next fall if
you're already thinking about that so
that being said Tim has asked to run a
couple of polls just to get started we'd
love to get a sense of the folks in the
room right now so did you see Tim's
original webinar a couple weeks ago we
sort of laid out his experience with
mastery learning and the results he was
getting and it looks like with about
two-thirds of the votes coming into him
there's actually a huge chunk of new
fans here more than three-quarters
actually so definitely a lot of folks
who could use a little bit of a
refresher okay and just to help helped
him out as well tell us what grade level
you teach that'll sort of help us tailor
obviously Tim is coming at this from a
sixth grade perspective but he'll make
sure to speak to the realities of other
grade levels as well and thanks everyone
for participating so quickly that's
awesome go ahead and share those results
and so it's him lots of fellow
elementary school folks but definitely a
nice mix of folks all the way up to the
college level in fact so lots of hunger
for the kinds of things you're sharing
that being said him I'm gonna basically
turn over to you because you've again
been so generous with your time and your
expertise to put together a whole nother
slide deck for us which also by the way
is attached in the handout section you
know I'll be emailed to you along with
the recording Tim is gonna spend about
30 minutes walking through all this
and then we're gonna kick your questions
live from the audience so Tim thank you
again take it away
okay well since there was a good chunk
of the live audience who have not seen
the original webinar let me first highly
recommend that you go back and watch
that but I will go a little bit slower
than anticipated on the initial review
material so that you're caught up to
speed so let's see do I have my screen
showing correctly commentary writing
clear
the slides are correct okay good okay so
mastery learning with Khan Academy and
how to achieve massive results so just
off the bat I want you to know that as a
sixth grade teacher in a low-income area
in the high desert area of California
and halfway between LA and Vegas my kids
are like most kids in America they're
not they're not coming from affluent
homes ten percent of them come to me at
grade level
ninety percent below grade level half of
them far below and nearly all of my
students are reading two or more years
below grade level when they come to me
and so comparing my class this is my
class down here comparing my class with
the state of California and the county I
teach in and the district I teach in you
can see where my students are relative
to all those this is a passing grade in
fifth grade and then sixth grade
normalizing the scores so you can
compare apples to apples of growth and
my students were a good about 20 points
below the average California student
which is still really far below and and
we'll talk about more of this later but
once you see my kids are not at grade
level so much like most of your students
as well and so in September 2016 I
watched a TED talk from Sal and you
really need to go watch this TED talk
and write it about the I think it's the
4 minute 30-second mark somewhere in
there Sal gives a powerful analogy of
education under the old school model is
kind of like
imagine of building a building like a 2
or 3 storey building or even taller and
giving instead of a fixed expectation of
the building being safe and solid and
firmly on a great foundation instead
basing your building on a timeline
saying for example alright you have two
weeks to build the foundation do what
you can and two weeks later the building
inspector comes and he says well you got
some wet cement over here you don't have
some foundational posts over there
that's pretty good
you got an 80% build the next level well
everybody knows in their right mind if
you keep up with that analogy from first
floor to second floor to third floor
eventually the building is going to
crumble and that's exactly like the way
we run education in America we say oK
you've got nine months so do what you
can and we don't have time to go back
and fix the foundation of the years
before these kids come to us we just
have to teach to the current grade-level
standards and they get what they get and
you pass them on and and you give them a
good grade if they try hard but really
did they pass the state test you
probably not so the big takeaway from
Sal's talks is this idea of mastery
learning if you see that at the bottom
there mastery learning is a different
mindset it's developing each skill to
fluency and long-term retention where
the fixed variable is mastery rather
than the time allotted you say okay I
don't care how long it takes you to
learn let's say I'm solving single
variable equations but you're gonna
master this before the state test you
might take longer than most kids you
might learn it after the quiz we take
but you're gonna learn this and that's
the expectation versus you got a week
and if you don't learn it too bad we're
moving on your grade stuck for that that
assignment that's skill mastery learning
is a different mindset we'll talk more
about that later so I decided after
watching that video from Sal that I was
totally done with building on building
on these dangerous foundations of
unstable mathematical concepts these
kids just didn't grasp what the meaning
of numbers were a place value fractions
what equations are and why we're
subtracting or adding to both sides at
the same time they just think that math
is just about memorizing algorithms as
opposed to truly understanding what's
going on so I decided that from now on
I'm gonna teach students with the solid
foundation and Khan Academy was going to
help me make that happen so in fall 2016
I chose three years ago now four school
years ago pretty much to take my kids
back to kindergarten we're gonna go back
to kindergarten with the help of Khan
Academy and master all these skills so
that we have a solid foundation to build
on so beautifully Khan Academy has all
these different grade level courses so I
assigned K through five in addition to
my sixth grade standards that my sixth
graders are supposed to learn and I
expected them to master everything and
let's see what happened so after three
school years of doing this each of the
past three school years my sixth graders
have grown their results have looked
like this you see that little dot on the
Left vandenberg 1819 60 points below if
you look at California I picked the best
growth for California students the
largest educational market in the nation
the best growth of the last three years
cohort growth they grew that year
seventeen twenty seventeen eighteen
school year they grew one-point-two
points towards a passing score now even
just a flat year of growth is good that
means you gave them a year harder test
and they stayed at the same level so you
kept them where they were by teaching
them a whole year's worth of material
they stayed about where they were so
even just flat growth is good well
here's what happened with my kids after
using this mastery learning model going
back and filling in the gaps we went
from sixty points below to 34 points
above all told is about 94 95 points of
growth on average for every student in
my class every kid went up
the one kid who went up the most he went
up 193 points he was an IEP special ed
kid one of the most um you know sweet
boy but one of the most hyperactive ADHD
boys that ever had in 25 years of
teaching and he grew immensely thanks to
Khan Academy and so did the whole rest
of the class so these are the kids yeah
their lives were changed forever this is
real you know if those kids look like
you're kids you know just your normal
average American student well there you
go
that's them just like your class if they
can do it so can your kids do too so how
do you make this happen
first I highly recommend this is new
material from here on out for those of
you have watched the former mmm-hmm
webinar we're gonna deep dive into my
brief points the first webinar first
familiarize yourself with what mastery
learning actually is okay mastery
learning watched these two videos and
the one linked up above in a slide deck
up above those three videos from Sal
Khan himself where he explains what
master learning is really wrap your mind
around that a lot of the questions I've
received in the last three weeks about
half of them have come to me from
teachers I can tell they really haven't
quite grasped what mastery learning is
they still want to teach under the old
model and you know bless them for
wanting to reach out and try some new
tricks that might work but if you really
want huge growth you really got accept
and dive deep dive into this mastery
learning model if you want to see what
this looks like in a classroom in fact
in my classroom that's the video linked
there and then you can watch my earlier
webinar right there on that link so you
can see all that for the first go-around
we had so I'm moving on so here are some
best practices for mastery learning
first some disclaimers every classroom
and school and districts situation is
different you need to adjust and make
this work for your students there's no
one-size-fits-all you need to use your
professional judgment
you still need to fall
whatever rules and expectations from
your your department your grade-level
team your administrators your district
at the same time it certainly helped
when I went to my principal and I asked
permission to try something vastly
different and he gave me a permission to
try just one year if my state test
results went up and he let me keep doing
it and that's exactly what happened
number two disclaimer this is a major
paradigm shift from the traditional time
driven learning model to the mastery
driven learning model you need to think
differently you need to think
differently from okay I'm going to teach
it and we're gonna do some practice so
mark and I'm gonna give a quiz and
whatever grade they got that's it we're
moving on this is a different mindset
where kids can still go back in and
continue to master skills while still
keeping up with a class on the new stuff
and grades are never solid until report
cards come out that's when grades are
locked in number 3 disclaimer for many
if not most students in America and in
the world really
this is a matter of educational life and
death are you willing to treat it as
such or are you just gonna stick with
the epically failed time driven status
quo you've got to decide look you might
be the last chance your students ever
have you might be the only teacher in
their whole k12 educational life who
will say you know what enough is enough
I'm gonna make sure my kids get the
foundation they need maybe for high
school teachers you're gonna make them
do early math arithmetic and pre-algebra
elementary teachers early math and
arithmetic only in addition to your
current grade level material but you got
to decide hey am I gonna change their
life or are they just gonna continue to
pretend they're passing classes because
they try hard but they never really
master it they fail the state test every
year their learning is fake we're lying
to parents about their grades and a is
not really an a just means they're
they're nice well-behaved and work hard
on homework and classwork and I give
them an A and I move them on and even
though they just failed the state test
or are you gonna just say the buck stops
here I'm gonna make a difference we're
gonna do something different
and change his kids lives so I hope you
join me in that adventure but that's up
to you make sure you get permission from
administrators or your department team
or whatever you need so that you're not
in trouble for doing what I believe is
morally and ethically right for all kids
all right so here's some here's some
tips getting more in detail these main
points one through the first nine of
these are from the original webinar but
the details underneath are new for
people to see so we'll look at these in
detail slowly one at a time so here we
go I mean so number one be honest and
face the state test facts where are your
students actually at look at their state
test scores from the year before or
whatever district diagnostic tests or
anything that'll show the real truth of
how they compare compared to state
expectations and national norms and so
on
where are they really at if their
previous year teacher said they got an A
or a B that might mean they're a good
student but that doesn't mean they
mastered the skills from the previous
year how many times have you told
yourself what were they teaching them
the year before and I guarantee you that
that teacher the year before was
thinking the same thing in August
September at the start of the year or
two and so on and so on all the way down
in kindergarten what were they teaching
them in preschool and preschool is
saying what were they teaching them at
home so that's not your business what is
your business is where are they at right
now so I highly recommend that you focus
on your students actual cohort growth
history where are they growing and how
did your students you just graduated the
year before how did they grow before I
got to tell you I I also taught high
school in junior high
not just sixth grade even though the
bulk of my 25 years was sixth grade and
even Jeremy doesn't know this for six
years I I was a adjunct professor at the
University of Redlands in California us
teacher credential program and I work
with student teachers as they're once a
week symposium teacher as they check in
during their
the hardest semester they're teaching
life it's called student teaching we've
all been through that so I've seen it
all we all know about high school
teachers junior high teachers elementary
teachers who might be very proud of
their state test scores you know maybe
they're kids they're average scores in
their class were at grade level but if
you look at their growth they might have
actually gone down maybe they came to
them at an advanced above grade level
score but by the time they graduated
them their scores actually went down
they might still be at grade level but
they didn't actually keep them level or
bring them up which to me is what a
successful teacher is so look at that
growth history and be honest with
yourself about that and so when I saw
that I said I need to do something
different because it's not working so
focus on growth not the final scores and
then finally if possible discuss the
growth data with your team your
department administration and most
importantly parents and students so I
highly recommend this this is what I do
at back-to-school night and
parent-teacher conferences show the
whole class results and then provide
individual student results individually
I'm not going to show any individual
scores but I'd have loaded up what I
showed at the start of this school year
on Jeremy are you able to see this yep
okay so this is what I showed at the
start of last school this school year
this is my previous school years kids
the same kids you just saw in that chart
where they grew up where they grew a lot
this is basically almost the same scores
every year they come to me in the
previous year this is what they look
like the previous year about three kids
at grade level
that's this in the green here nobody in
advanced above grade level I'd sure
would like to be one of those teachers
that gets a population up here and a
bunch of kids down here above a grade
level this is a typical report for my
district on how kids did on state test
the year before and this is where most
of my kids are now they call this
a nice word they call this standards
nearly met but if green level 3 means at
grade level
what do you call yellow level 2 that
means not at grade level to me that
means they failed the previous year in
my case they failed fifth grade and then
here's the kids the biggest chunk of my
kids far below grade level far below and
I can't tell you how many of these kids
got A's and B's from their teachers in
fifth grade because they worked hard
they were nice they did their best and
they got an A or a B and their parents
gonna mean to say my child never got
less than an A or never got less than a
B on their report cards in math so what
are you gonna do with my kid this year
well I show them the reality you need to
show your parents the reality this is
reality do you want me to give your
child an a when they failed the grade
level or do you want me to be honest
with you and do something differently to
make a difference besides parents this
is what happened and this is what I do I
show them all these these are failing
scores in each domain concepts
procedures problem solving modeling data
communicating reasoning orange is
failing like far below the gray is could
be at could be below it's like near
grade level and the the light blue is
like advanced now it's so good this is
reality you need to show your parents
your administrators your team reality
and have a reality check with them but
then show them what happens with the
growth if the if you do this for one
year show them the growth so I show them
before and then here comes the after
ready for this boom those are the exact
same kids leveled up those 90 or so
points yeah there is one kids still down
here in the red but I'll tell you this
kid actually went up like a hundred
points and then all those kids that were
in the red moved up to yellow and all
those kids that were in the yellow moved
up to green and all these advanced kids
moved up this is real and look at all
these these domain scores so look at all
these advanced and all this orange like
almost went away this is real growth and
when when I had success the very first
year this is what I do I show the next
year's parents here's the before and
you're kids by the way or just like this
and if you want the
after I can make this up and if you want
it so show that data and be in until
then until you have some data to show
that to administrators talk to them
about where they're really at and why
are we keep beating a dead horse and
being like that fly hitting their head
against the window thinking they'll
eventually get through um
you got to do something different the
definition of insanity is continuing to
do what fails over and over the people
say expecting it to change so quit the
insanity and do something different so
be honest with the state test results so
back to our presentation I think it's
this over here okay
so show them all that next number to
acknowledge that math is cumulative
prerequisite skills are exactly that pre
required not pre suggested you can't
teach kids how to multiply divide out of
subtract fractions and and mixed numbers
unless they even understand what a
fraction is and I can't even figure that
out until they understand the meaning of
numbers and numbers sense and place
value and all of that so you they need
to master those skills otherwise they
will continue for the rest of their
lives until they choose to quit school
or think that they're dumb when they're
not they're just gonna think the school
math is all about algorithms memorizing
algorithms and having no clue what it
all means so get away from memorizing
algorithms focus on meaning and
understanding what's really going on by
going back even back to kindergarten and
having to master those prerequisite
skills and number sense concepts number
three in order to do that use Khan
Academy to remediate and fill in
foundational gaps by assigning remedial
course mastery expectations I assigned
early math or you can individually saw
in K one two three whatever grade levels
are below you also the arithmetic course
covers I would say kindergarten through
seventh grade arithmetic dealing with
positive negative integers add subtract
multiply divide and order of operations
that little bit gets into seventh-grade
as well so that's a good review for
junior and high school teachers
and then the pre-algebra course is
excellent review for secondary teachers
teaching above pre-algebra so that's an
excellent review next teach you're still
teaching you don't just say all right
every day go on Khan and figure it out
yourself
you still teach the grade-level Common
Core standards to mastery don't just
cover the standards master them expect
mastery number five believe that every
child can learn it's called growth
mindset so what you should do is you
should assign like the first week of
school and I know it's kind of late now
but you can still assign this to your
kids now change your lives now don't
wait till the fall a sinus remotely is
we're all doing remote learning the
growth mindset lessons on Khan Academy
tell your kids get on there tell them
it's extra credit tell them it'll change
their lives it's totally worth it if you
haven't done it already so if you go to
Khan Academy let me pull up that tab
okay up here in a courses tab over here
in college careers and more is this
growth mindset of course so assign that
to your kids it's amazing that videos
are amazing do them together as a class
talk about them do the activities it's
fantastic so definitely be doing that
okay and then back to the presentation
okay growth mindset also a part of
growth mindset really emphasize and
teach the value of error analysis learn
from mistakes mistakes are good talk but
the quickest most of the fastest growth
that kids make is when they stop and
learn from mistakes okay what did I do
wrong and that's where the growing is
the the most powerful and sticks with
them the longest and the growth mindset
videos and lessons talk about that so
make sure you do that my number six
teach supports teach support and you're
really teaching but then you support
them you let them use Khan Academy which
gives instant feedback after every
question did they get it did they
understand it or not and then allow let
go and allow them to have self agency
and initiative let them own it so let me
go back in Khan Academy
up here okay so over here on on progress
if you go to your progress tab I have
assigned the sixth grade and several
other courses now this is my current
class I've changed their names to just
to two letters first and last name of
each so you don't know who Sue a little
you know privacy there for them but this
is my class progress and these low
performers down here these are special
ed kids and they're actually mastering
their their lower grade materials for
the first time in their life so I'm
still proud of them they're still gonna
have huge growth on the state test from
where they were last year even this kid
here who's at 38% mastery for sixth
grade on our practice state test
practices he is crushing the practice
state test with it above grade level
scores on half of the practice tests and
a great little scores for the other half
he's doing great and so are all the
other kids doing best that they've ever
done in their whole lives the Khan
Academy research which I leaned on
before I ever began this says that if
kids master 40% or more of their current
grade level standards they will
outperform their non khanacademy peers
that don't use Khan Academy by about 50%
on their state tests and kids who Master
60% from here and above will outperform
by 80% I'm pretty sure maybe Jeremy
afterwards can link the Khan Academy
page that shows that bar graph growth
compared to non Khan using kids so I
just want you know you might think well
we're almost out of the school year why
aren't more of your kids to him further
along I trust this this is real learning
not I covered it and I failed the test
these kids actually mastered this and
these kids all these kids it's sixty
percent approximately sixty percent or
higher I anticipate them achieving an
advanced above grade level that love a
one on that chart or at grade level but
definitely at grade level or above so
they're going to do great but then I use
these charts so going back in to teach
support teach support what I do is I go
into the unit the great little unit that
we're teaching I still teach so let's
say here's the unit we we actually
haven't even covered yet check this out
we have not even taught this unit at all
yet
but because my students have they I've
allowed them to have initiative and self
C and the ability to move forward
without me even teaching the unit a
third of my class is already halfway
done with the whole unit and then
another third is a quarter done or more
and it needs the kids that are you know
low and struggling and they're not to
this yet but when I get around to
teaching this unit next if we do come
back from the whole remote learning
thing that we're all going through right
now when I do teach this unit I've
already got half two thirds of my class
seated with with pre knowledge about
what is going on
so let's say and here's their growth on
each skill so what I do is I'll go to
the skill let's say I want to teach how
to calculate the mean so here 17 kids
still haven't gotten to proficient or
familiar with that so calculate the mean
I will teach this skill and probably the
next skill the median and and probably
this and this these I'll probably teach
three or four skills at once three or
four skills together over a good hour
and then I'll let them loose like okay
now now go do it I bet you can do it
just like we did together as a class
I'll use my own computer as like a
student and we do some problems together
as a class and then I I literally put
this up on the big screen and this they
would actually see their names but I'm
not letting you see their names and I'll
say ok you want to go to recess you need
to at least get to familiar to this
level before recess and you got 30
minutes before recess I bet you can get
too familiar especially since I'm here
to help you your neighbors are here to
help you the Khan videos and the
contents are all here to help you and as
long as kids work hard and do their best
and reach out for help and persist and
show grit and show growth mindset I let
them all go to recess and the ones that
are you know there's always kids that
choose not to work and I you know hold
them in now you as a high school teacher
junior high teacher you got different
privileges you know our powers that you
can have over them but that's what I do
or I might say okay by for homework by
tomorrow you need to all be over here at
proficient or you know at I'll let see
what we call this proficient
or try to be it mastered by taking a
unit exam so that's what I do I teach
and then I monitor this I'll even put
this on the big screen in my classroom
I'll project this whole screen and we I
train them as a class I say okay class
now here you see names where you are in
this chart has nothing to do with how
smart you are
this is all about just where you're at
right now so let's all work together as
a team and get up here to proficient
let's work together as a team and you
you kids who've become proficient or
mastered you're now the designated peer
tutors reach out to your table members
who are down here who are still
struggling and help them out and I'll
give big team points or class points if
we can get everybody moved up or all
that these kids go to recess early or
whatever so motivate kids like that and
then also show the growth charts okay
and just set a class culture of we're
here to support each other and everybody
who works hard is rewarded even if you
can't get up to proficient or familiar
if you work hard and reach out for help
hey you're you're moving on you're
getting all the privileges everybody
else gets but I need to see it I need to
see the effort and the belief that you
can learn by putting in the effort and
sweat equity so now back at the sixth
grade progress as I teach I'm monitoring
this chart and I'll show the class I'll
say okay class the median and we learn
what median means early on in the year
the middle kid in the class is right
here are you above or below and can you
catch them if you're down here and so
I'll do that or I might also I might say
hey so-and-so this kid right here did
you know that your friend is only 1%
ahead of you I bet if you work hard
tonight you can catch them up in fact
I'll pay you class cash or a raffle
ticket or some kind of class reward if
you can catch him up and then this kids
like oh no I don't want that to happen
I'm gonna I'm not gonna let you beat me
and so I have individual one 1v1
competitions as well using this data but
it's all this a class environment of
supporting and encouraging and you've
got to set that tone we are here to help
each other and you praise the kids you
grow a lot and move up and every kid can
do it and we really
even at especially at the unit level
they'll see bigger growth on the unit
level when you click on buy unit for
example that unit that I haven't even
taught yet they'll see growth more rapid
because within a unit it's less material
so their growth happens more quickly ok
so back to the presentation I just
wanted you to see that while I teach I
then can use this data to know who I
need to go help who is struggling and
who needs assistance so back to the
presentation so teach support but allow
them to work on their own and you saw
the results of that is like half the
class has already learned a whole chunk
of that unit that I haven't even taught
yet so make it make it real let them
have some it's some independence next
motivates encouraged praised reward and
celebrate what I do at the start of the
year I really really get them excited
about growth and and really believing
that they can do it so I emphasize the
mastery of the lower grade level skills
k12 these kids are like I can do this
I'm a 6th grader and they might secretly
struggle with some skills like mr.
Vanderberg I forgot what rhombus is can
you tell me what that is
or they they might not have ever truly
had the chance to learn or master what
some of these numbers cent skills are
did you know they start in Common Core
they start learning about distributive
property concepts pretty early so really
have them go through those those
foundational skills so but they
basically build confidence and velocity
by focusing on lower grade level review
remediation standards they're like well
I can do this look like now I know how
to look at the hands to quickly learn
how to do it it's easy its first grade
it's kindergarten I can do this and so
they learn how the system works while
it's still easy while secretly they
might come across something they
struggle with and they're like ok I need
to slow down and learn this get help
from my teacher while they're doing this
their self pride will skyrocket as
students build confidence and self
agency through grit and determination
utilizing help resources
as needed the videos the hints their
peer buddies and you the teacher and
even parents and older siblings at home
next part of this motivation piece use
those remedial courses and as they do
the remedial courses have them begin
with the course challenges because
they're supposedly you've already
covered as before then supposedly they
should be able to do it so say hey start
at the end do the course challenge and a
unit tests a few times and it'll what
that will do it will quickly bring them
up in their skill mastery a lot faster
than if they went skill by skill through
all the lessons it's a really rapid
advancement and then what they did not
answer correctly then they can go and
individually and work on those skills
have them do those course challenges
it's kind of like a final exam and end
of your test and also the unit tests a
few times each but be aware after so
many times some of the questions do
start to recycle so you don't want kids
doing that too many times and you'll
have to use your judgement where the
questions start to recycle they're just
memorizing answers copying answers down
and reusing them so I only let them do
them a few times maybe five times or so
and then right around ten times I think
questions start to recycle somebody
who's an expert ought to inform me on
that so and then if also at the start of
the year I focus on time on tasks like
first week of school I'll say hey guys
guess what I can see how hard you're
working so like for example I go
back up to this excellent feature called
activity overview this is set up for the
window of this semester grades finished
for first semester on December 16th so
ever since then this is their work since
then so what I might do I might set this
to just the last day or two and then
I'll sort by most minutes on task and
I'll reward I'll say ok kids I will
reward the top ten kids who work the
most tonight
now you're requiring homework is only
thirty minutes tonight but if you do
more than that well if you're one of the
top ten boy I'm gonna I'm gonna award
you big class cache or big team points
or some privilege or some reward or
something like that so they get hooked
on the successes of burning through
quickly those early gray level skills
and really mastering them next after a
while after a few weeks of that I phase
out of focusing on minutes on tasks
because you can fake the minutes on
tasks by just leaving the screen open
kids smart can start to figure that out
then I start focusing instead on skills
leveled up and I'll say okay the top the
top ten kids who level up the most
skills tonight for homework I'm gonna
give them big rewards so make sure
you're focusing on skills leveled up so
that's one way I really motivate the
kids I might set them individually
rewards or team rewards or class rewards
for all that so okay I'm back to the
presentation so that's what this is all
about about and so as you teach them to
rely on those videos hints elbow buddies
and you next praise and reward
individual team and whole class effort
and progress educational research has
shown that kids need three levels of
motivation usually you're higher
achieving kids what works with them the
best is individual motivation individual
rewards your average achieving kids need
more like small group rewards like a
team or a table group or maybe a class
versus a class if you're a high school
junior high teacher period versus period
and then the the lower kids they need
more whole class where they can blend in
and work as a whole giant team because
they know they can still
chip in and not not be singled out they
might be embarrassed if if their growth
is shown but boy if they chip in and
help the whole class achieve then they
will definitely help make a big
difference and their growth will still
go up without any individual focus on
them so that's basically a q-dubs
life-changing for me when I learned that
decades ago about motivating kids on
those three levels individual team and
whole class so reward and praise
accordingly next here's some ideas to do
all that Khan Academy has some free
certificates you can download Jeremy can
give you the link for that class cache
that's what I use or raffle tickets or
homework heroes or team points or
class-wide challenges or like I was
saying earlier 1v1 skill mastery
challenges Pitts friends against friends
who can you know I bet you can catch up
to your buddy this week or tonight or in
this class period if you work hard or
who can level up the most skills today
and just today only um and I like to
show unit and skill progress charts live
all with the culture of we are all we
are all here to support each other and
everybody who works hard I don't care
how low your progress is as long as you
work hard you will be praised and
rewarded okay another way to motivate
use grades Khan Academy should be used
for grades in fact I trust Khan Academy
better than most assignment assessments
by far based on mastery and for me a
grade is never locked in a grade can go
up if they keep leveling up their
mastery fer of course or a grade can go
down until report cards once report
cards happen their grade is locked in
especially semester report cards grades
are locked in but by the end of the year
they can keep working right now as we're
remote learning even though not not work
is not required because of the remote
learning equity concerns the kids can
still optionally keep working and they
are there leveling up their skills I've
had kids who've worked hours and hours
leveling up skills while they're at home
on their Chromebooks working on their
skills here's a pro tip that I suggest
you do what works best for you but I
highly recommend that you use Khan
Academy assignments for grades the
assignments there's a really fantastic
feature called assignments where you're
going to
sighing specific skills to kids and
they're super powerful for seeing how
the kids are doing and because it'll
tell you how the coal class did and on
every single question it's super
powerful but I highly recommend you use
that for grades sparingly unless you're
one of those teachers who have all the
time in the world to enter assignment
grades individual assignment grades into
your grade book and keep them updating
regularly so let's say they got a 67% on
one of the assignments you give them is
that locked in forever you know what
what about growth mindset and mastery
learning what if what if they learn that
skill later in the year and they redo
the assignment and they get a hundred
percent on it you're gonna go back and
change it well I don't have time for all
that so I do use the assignments feature
to signal the kids what I want them to
work on and also if I just want to get a
pulse on how well they're learning as a
class and what's specific kinds of
questions I need to reteach but I don't
use assignments for grades barely ever
instead let me show you my assignment
book hopefully my grade book did not go
good okay all right so this is my grade
book I slid it over so you cannot see
the names of the kids but this is my
grades
here's early math and you can see at the
bottom of that black box it says this
assignment is weighted 0.333 so
one-third of the value of my regular
sixth grade assignment early a third
grade that's half the value because
three is half of six sixth grade and
arithmetic those are full value and
notice that's out of a hundred points I
just go into every two or three weeks
into their Khan Academy progress scores
on the progress tab that you already saw
and I just update this and I say okay
based on the progress chart so let's say
we're talking let's see here
let's say back to this some of you've
already seen his progress chart this is
the prop the pacing guide that I use
let's say it's let's say it's week five
of the school year they should have
let's say you assigned kindergarten
first second third fourth fifth all
those to your kids they should have a
hundred percent of kindergarten mastered
a hundred percent of first hundred
percent of second sixty-three percent of
third thirty-one
% of 4th and 16% of 5th and 6 and
arithmetic should be mastered by now by
the week that ends on September 13th so
that's what I make it in my gradebook I
make the sixth grade course out of 16
points and if they're past that great
they have over a hundred percent on that
if they're less than 16 percent then
it'll mark it accordingly and so I keep
typing that in and keep updating and as
the week's go on I change what it's out
of and eventually this is my pacing
guide some of you have already seen this
and it'll be linked it is link Jeremy
will make sure it's linked somewhere
after this presentation by spring break
everything is done everything should be
hundred percent and that's where we are
we're at spring break so back to the
gradebook here it is so by now
everything should be a hundred percent
and just a couple hours ago I went in
and I updated grades based on what kids
have been doing on remote learning and
this is how they're doing how much
they've mastered of the whole grade
level and I just keep updating at every
two or three weeks so I'm only changing
these grades two or three times maybe
twice a month at most this is a math
facts I use a separate third-party math
facts program add subtract multiply
divide fresh fraction decimal percent
conversions things like that and then I
also grade effort and well that's in a
slide show in a second but I may as well
talk about it right now
I give an effort grade and it's based on
how hard the class is working I
basically take the top ten kids and
basically the 10th kid in the class has
worked this semester since December 16th
3,000 minutes on task so I make it out
of 300 and then move the decimal place
over so all these kids with 300 points
they have an effort rate of basically
300 out of 300 100% anybody with less
than that because they're not going home
and doing their homework we're not
working in class like they should it's
less than 300 but this is just a little
grade to buffer because look I make it
says this assignment the bottom of that
black box this assignment is weighted at
point zero point one its value so it's
really a 30 point assignment but it's a
nice little buffer to reward those kids
who are working hard and the kids like
this one who are really smart look at
this great scores mastering most of them
fantastically but that students not
trying so hard they really should be
trying hard so it kind of lowers our
grate a little bit for effort so that's
still part of the grade so okay so back
to the presentation so that's how I do
grades but I do recommend using the
assignment sparingly but you do what
works for you but but make sure you
follow the mastery learning model if you
want to be able to do all this next let
effort count we just talked about that
okay but watch out for grade inflation I
I have taught high school and junior
high I have tutored dozens and dozens of
high school and junior high and college
students and I know how some secondary
teachers inflate grades by knowing their
kids will fail the state test that boy
if they work hard on their homework and
and they're nice and class and try hard
in class boy I'll give them an A cuz
they do their homework even though all
their homework is wrong well I don't
give grades like that I'll get a little
bit of an effort grade that'll braise
them up a little bit for their effort
which Khan Academy measures for you
beautifully and easily but make sure
it's balanced so the kids who work hard
but have don't learn a material they're
not just getting an A and a should mean
they're mastering the material at least
proficient or better so you you balance
it out so it's just right so the real
learning is really happening letter G
use non Khan assessment scores to verify
learning and to disincentivize cheating
what do I mean by that so back to the
gradebook over here you'll see some
other your grades this is common
formative assessments that my grade
level does some of you know about PLC's
professional learning communities we
have common formative assessments and
we've been doing practice date tests the
interim assessment blocked us they call
them in California these are like real
practice state unit tests and I use
those but I balanced them out so that it
does not skew the scores so this way if
the kid is proving that they're learning
on third-party assessments they're still
going to do great on the test make sure
these other assessments quizzes and
tests are rigorous and truly match the
state standards and they're rigorousness
but also you give enough weight and
value to mastering skills on Kanaka
me that they're still passing your class
with a great grade but make sure their
learning is real this is what I mean by
avoid cheating disincentivize cheating
have you ever had kids cheat
does that ever happen I know with any
sort of teaching cheating can happen
well on Khan Academy kids can open up a
new tab and go to Google calculator and
typing the problem on a calculator or
use their their calculator they have in
their desk and and do the work without
doing it for real
now Khan Academy sometimes does give a
calculator and they should use that just
like a state test to do that to at least
in California but if they're doing
superb on their Khan Academy mastery but
they fail my third-party non Khan
Academy assessments I become highly
suspicious of their learning over on
Khan and if a kid fails a quiz or test
and they claim their Khan data shows
that they were mastering it I say okay
tell you what
do that unit test on Khan and I'm
watching you I'm gonna make sure that
you're not using a calculator go ahead
get started and then they might say oh
well you know III I forgot how to do it
well then you never learned it to begin
with because Khan mastery is all about
long-term learning that's weights design
so you discover the cheaters real quick
that way another form of cheating is
your peer tutor buddies I really have to
train the class make sure that peer
tutors are when they're helping their
friends make sure that the hints are
showing because when you click hints
open Khan Academy will not give credit
for that question being answered so make
sure the hints are showing then I can I
allow their friends to help all they
want because the hints are showing that
means that won't get credit for
answering right so they can discuss it
with them and talk them through the
problem step by step no big deal but if
the hints are not showing then they're
cheating because they're gonna get how
to do it and get the answer and Khan
don't think they knew how to do it on
their own so make sure that's going on
okay back to slide show okay knock on
assessments letter H keep intrinsic and
extrinsic motivation balanced
emphasizing intrinsic motivation that's
self pride and self-worth is just
amazing it totally skyrockets by
remember most teachers don't teach for
free so some extrinsic reward is okay
hey I still need a paycheck to you know
take care of my family even though I
would teach for free if I could but I
still need a paycheck well our kids some
of them it's okay to to get you know
class cash or homework passes or special
rewards or privileges or whatever
extrinsic rewards you want to give with
the balance of the major focus is
intrinsic reward believing that they can
do it we have an on number 10 release
control give your kids independence once
you've taught several skills or whatever
skill you just taught let them go and
allow for personalized variable pace
while setting high expectations toward
proficiency and mastery and trust that
the learning is real I mean God make
sure they're not cheating but make sure
they're really doing it on their own at
their own pace while you're supporting
them and their friends are supporting
them trust it it works it really is real
number 11 this is something a lot of
teachers don't think about till it
happens you need to use your own
professional judgment regarding your
special ed kids also the kids that
transfer you to your class or school
late in the year and hard-working low
ability kids that just struggle with
math all in my class the policy is all
hard-working kids you get a c-minus or
higher and I make sure I follow whatever
laws are in place with students IEP s
and are required for me to do with their
special ed needs and low ability kids
hey I promise all parents cuz some
parents are like well you know I've
never had my kid have to actually earn
their a before what if they work hard
and get a D because they're low at math
I say hey your kid works hard I promised
them a c-minus or better and that
usually parents are like that the way
they respond is usually finally for the
first time in my child's life and even
in my own life when I was as a parent
when I was young is the first time this
teacher is actually gonna grade my kid
based on them actually learning not just
cuz they're cute and smile and act nice
so they love that number 12
don't forget come April May you still
got a review for the big test state
tests or whatever you got
do in your state and now this year a lot
of states and I know federally because
of the whole coronavirus thing state
tests in California and I think across
the nation have been canceled or
postponed or something like that but for
next year when we get back to normal
Sun you still got a review because some
of their skill mastery was months ago
months ago so review with unit tests on
Khan Academy the course challenges make
the kids retake those they're gonna say
but I forgot how to do it well that's
good you'll get to learn what you need
to review and non cons assessments use
all those number thirteen be aware with
any digital platform cheating is
possible we've already talked about that
number fourteen bus point remind them
constantly they are changing their lives
forever this is real this is going to
change their lives as it has for my
students the last three years and I know
for a fact based on the the practice
state tests and my kids were taking that
this would have been the fourth year had
we gotten to take the real-estate test
that my kids would have just blown their
previous growth out of the water with
huge growth I predicted my kids probably
would have grown about a hundred points
this year if we had a state test on
average and growth so here's some
resources Jeremy you're gonna take it
over from here so it's all you first of
all huge shout out back to you Tim this
is amazing like I think the the very
first webinar you did was kind of an
appetizer and hors d'oeuvre if you will
this is absolute the main course so I
think folks are peeling both really
satiated but also hungry for the next
thing burning questions for you don't
don't forget forget you guys can get our
recording and go back and rewind and
re-watch and pause and and email Jeremy
bug in with your questions yeah so Tim
Tim DeGeneres think that he is offered
his own email address in the last
webinar and live to regret that so
please put all questions to me going
forward I do not regret that I was very
happy to do that but I'm now wiser so go
ahead Jeremy I want to address the
elephant in the room that's coming in
from Keith as well as a couple other
educators Keith says this is amazing and
I would love to do this at the start of
the school year but give me the very
unusual circumstance
find ourselves in with ten weeks left
remote learning what would you do if
someone was starting totally brand-new
with this right now at this time okay so
if I was a teacher we're all doing
remote learning something like that keep
up with your normal assignments don't
change things right now you're gonna
have major kickback from parents and
probably administrators who hear from
those angry parents don't change your
class routines right now but what I
would do I would allow an extra credit
opportunity to buffer great especially
for the struggling kids make sure that
it's balanced in a way that doesn't warp
their grades they still focus on your
current grade level assignments but I
would go ahead and assign for extra
credit the early math the arithmetic and
for secondary the pre-algebra courses
and tell the kids
hey this is extra credit and I'll give
double extra credit to the the two or
three kids who master the most or grow
the most on these or whatever I don't
know you use your own teacher magic you
know your kids the best but I would
still assign this as an extra credit
assignment as an easy review tell them
hey this is easy but don't forget to
start with the course challenges because
they'll quickly level up and they'll
quickly show that well I can do this oh
wait I I never learned this kindergarten
skill I I don't know what this is
because this happens every year with my
kids there's so much they learned that
they did not learn in kindergarten first
second third grade but by going back you
should see the little looks on their
faces like wow I I
I never realized that we were supposed
to learn this and now I can't do this
little skill for the this poor little
kid so I would do that assign it as an
extra credit optional assignment unless
you're allowed to make it required use
your own judgment that's what I would do
and let it enhance and supplement grades
otherwise they'll be like well you know
why am I doing this
well it'll change your life is what
it'll do and I tell them this is great
summer work tell the parents work on
this over the summer and they can keep
you posted as teachers you can keep your
Khan Academy classes and watch their
growth and encourage them over the
summer if you have district emails with
them and you can still confer with them
through a district channel so all right
that's my advice for that okay amazing
so now let's fast forward a little bit
to September let's assume that we get
back to normalcy it's important fingers
crossed
even if you want to do this under
perfect circumstances and I'm one
question we're getting this is sort of
really nicely put by Kelly where do you
get the time Kelly says we have a
four-day week so semester has about 65
to 70 days if we take away testing FFA
sports so maybe 50 to 60 days 40 to 50
scanners per grade etc etc how do you
make time for this in this crazy hectic
world that educators inhabit hey like I
said at the beginning the first
disclaimer you need to make this fit
your situation your parameters your
boundaries and guidelines so if you
notice that on task data my kids have
average since December 16th the start of
grading for the second semester because
I have grades done on December 16th for
the first semester my average
hard-working student averaged about an
hour a day of con activity do your kids
have time for an hour a day that counts
class time and homework time I bet you
can make that happen especially if you
motivate kids to go above and beyond and
especially when your students begin to
realize that you are gonna grade based
on mastery not based on did they try
hard but fail the quiz you know you
don't just give an A because they tried
hard but they can't actually do the work
when you start showing an expectation of
grading based on mastery your 30 kids
are used to getting all A's and B's even
for the high class especially for the
high classes that come to you at the
secondary level they'll start to realize
wait wait wait you mean I have to
actually like learn this not just turn
in a homework page with all the wrong
answers you know they're used to that
but they need to start getting used to
is they have to actually prove that they
learned it and kids love the fact that
you could actually track their growth
and so they start working harder and
they start working above and beyond 30
minutes of homework a night and at the
secondary level most teachers are
comfortable safe and legally protected
to assign our homework at night I bet
they can get that done now the balance
that as I've been answering a lot of
teachers questions the balance of
practice skill practice I've
he's about half of their time 50% of
their time on Khan spent on sixth-grade
work and the other half of their time
spent on K through five review material
or the early math class and the
arithmetic class that's what I do this
class I have this year is even 20 points
lower than last year
as they came to me and so I learned out
for the first semester hey I'm gonna
adjust I'm gonna take away the fourth
grade in fifth grade and just make them
do early math their grade and arithmetic
so also be flexible but there is time if
you start making them prove their
learning as opposed to making math about
busy work and memorizing algorithms so
that's my thoughts on that you can do it
and even if you start making module E in
the time that you do have they will
still learn far better than under the
old time driven model focus on mastery
not get done what you can in two weeks
and that's it great and Tim do you have
time for one last question oh I have all
the time you want Jeremy make this as
long as you want well I gotta get you
back to your family because they're
gonna wonder if you've been abducted
being that one teacher left at your
school
let me ask you is one last question cuz
I think you've actually had a lot of the
other questions that were asked about
what you do with not for homework what
do you do in terms of signing course
master goals I think the really powerful
thing about the session is now as an
educator myself I can actually visualize
what it looks like I think the one
missing piece that hammam is asking
about is what are you doing while your
students are working on Khan
can you sort of vision up let's
visualize how they thinks so if you
watch the video earlier in the slide
deck about what it looks like in my
classroom
you know you teach they take notes you
practice it as a class and then while
they're working on Khan I'm circulating
among the students on tracking that the
growth data on that skill or that that
particular skill or that unit and seeing
who's moving up and who needs help and
touching base with each of those kids
that are struggling and making sure
they're getting the help they need and
moving along I'm not just sitting at my
desk reading a sports page
you know not at espn.com I'm circulating
around and helping the kids as needed
incur
pure buddies to reach out to their
friends hey there's somebody at your
table it needs help can you help him out
that kind of stuff so I don't have one
math class I have thirty math classes
and thirty peer tutors sometimes odd my
lowest kids master skills first and they
become the the peer tutor master to help
the kids that might be smarter
supposedly but haven't learned it yet
so you're actively engaged you're not
babysitting cool I love it well I think
you've conspired us especially in this
relatively dark time to aim for
something even brighter and higher in
our own educational lives I know there
are a lot of questions left out there
and I've promised to protect him sanity
and his inbox so please shoot me
questions with anything that's on your
mind I'm Jeremy shilling at
khanacademy.org and on behalf of Khan
Academy and behalf of Tim I want to
thank you for investing in this I know
our time is very scarce right now and we
have a lot on our shoulders but the fact
that you showed up the fact that you
sort of learned from what tim has done
and sort of taught himself the hard way
I think says a lot and Tim thank you so
much for making us all wiser with
sharing your expertise and paying it
forward so thank you all again yeah hear
me if I can you say one less thing
teachers trust your professional
judgment do what works for you and your
kids there's no one right way and you
learn by doing so just you just got to
dive in and go for it cool and on that
note I'm hope everyone has a wonderful
evening then a great start to the
weekend wishing you all tremendous
success good night everybody
Cheers